welcome to the show Steve how you doing
this morning great to be with you Ryan
great time of the year looking forward
to hoops Madness I bet I bet all right
brackets came out yesterday three ACC
teams get the number one seeds what was
uh moment you take away with that well I
do think as the year went along that the
ACC really demonstrated they had more
teams at the top with the firepower the
overall strength their prowess to win a
national championship were to punch
through two Final Four
Carolina you know went on a roll
Florida State went on a roll Duke with
Sian Williamson has been unbeatable
without Zion Williamson they're you know
capable of being beat Virginia you know
pretty much through the regular season
beat everybody
they faced other than Duke and until the
conference tournament loss had been
dominant in their play so didn't really
surprise me there were three number one
seeds I think earlier in the year the
Big Ten maybe was leading when it came
to the best conference in the country
and they still have a great league and a
deep league and are well represented as
they should be in this tournament field
but I think it's fair to say there are
more teams the ACC capable winning the
national title than any other conference
is it was there a team that you thought
what was the biggest team that you
thought got left out of the brackets
yesterday you know North Carolina
Greensboro has to be feeling a bit
chapter salty to win 28 games and be
left out of the tournament field that's
difficult
I'm sure NC State because they were in
the ACC such a tough league that has
three number one seeds so the selection
committee I think got it right overall
but it's never going to be perfect and
as a result there's always a couple
teams left out and it was a very fluid
you know bracket as so often it is
it was coming down the homestretch you
know st. John's interestingly the last
team seated in the 68 the last team to
get in and interestingly they could also
be a team that gets hot they didn't play
well down the stretch losing five of
seven and lost by 32 in the conference
tournament to Marquette and that had me
concerned that from an optic standpoint
they might be left out but they had done
enough work early with a win over VCU
and the two big ones over Marquette in
the regular season and they got a
dramatic comeback in the garden against
Villanova that I think ultimately was
the difference if they don't win that
Villanova game they don't get in but now
they're a team that could be very
dangerous patient Arizona State in the
first four coming up this week yeah
speaking of the first four right it came
to fruition a little while back what do
you think of having 68 teams to start
this out rather than the 64 that played
so long against another team an
opportunity to to get in but do you
really feel like it we're watching
Arizona State go back to Dayton for the
second time with Bobby Hurley if they
don't make it out of that are they still
able to go out and believe that they
were an NC Journal NCAA tournament team
it's interesting I think the way you
know the the first four has evolved is
what gives him more credibility you know
initially when it was just one game but
now that it's a full day or two days in
Dayton and actually had the opportunity
between my UCLA and st. John's head
coaching ten year I worked at ESPN for
seven years and Brent Musburger and I
called those early games and even that
when we were calling those those games
we we kind of looked into the future and
then we're thinking wouldn't it be great
if they had a one or a two day event and
so I think it now has a better feel to
it
and it's great for Dayton and and if
you're you know a player or coach you'd
rather not be playing in that scenario
but at the end of it you're happy to
have that
opportunity to dance to keep the season
alive to extend your season and we're
going to eventually see at some point a
team that starts there and makes it to a
Final Four and you know may-maybe a
while before we see that but eventually
with some of these power conference
teams that come out of their tough
leagues you know bloodied but unbowed as
I like to say teams that have ten eleven
twelve thirteen losses but unlike
college football where two losses and
your season of a championship or what in
the national championship in college we
see consistently now teens with 10 11 12
13 losses didn't make it to the Final
Four or compete for a national
championship or even win a national
championship because those losses inform
a better way to play and if you can be
resilient and bounce back now you're
playing at your best late in the season
and you've seen everything as you get
into the tournament you've had to
overcome much like a metaphor for life
where we draw on our experiences and
they inform a better way if we've
learned from the setbacks and that's
what good coaches are able to do like
good parents or teachers it's all about
each day growing and learning so I
overall like that first four and I think
it's grown to a point where now it has
the credibility and it's kind of a
precursor to tipping it up on Thursday
you're and we're listening to Steve
Lavin Fox Sports NCAA basketball analyst
I wanted to get into the handful of
teams you think could win the national
championship I thought it was more or
less four or five a few weeks ago but I
really think with the with the way the
tournaments played out a lot of the
number one seeds knocked off some other
teams Auburn wins the SEC Michigan State
continues to win what are the number of
teams you think of that are capable of
actually winning the national
championship this year you know I've got
in my Final Four and of course we all
know that our brackets get turned upside
down it's why we call it madness so
let's begin with just enjoying the
madness as our office pools and brackets
get turned upside down that's the
beautiful aspect of trying to predict
what 18 to 22 year olds are going to do
under duress with the spotlight of the
n-c-double-a tournament now being as
great as any sporting event in the world
you know for my final four I've got Duke
Kentucky Gonzaga and Tennessee Duke out
of the East Kentucky of the Midwest
obviously Gonzaga in the West Tennessee
in the south but a team like Syracuse
dangerous that could be a tough matchup
in the second round if they punch
through and they end up facing Gonzaga
that zone defense Jim Boeheim no
stranger to the tournament and the
adjustments he makes within that zone
whether he collapses it to the basket
area like an accordion or he can extend
it as well to get out in the passing
lanes to trap particular players or
based on the clock time score personnel
does a lot of things it's not a hands up
Harry
you know stationary 2-3 zone it's it
morphs it's a chameleon and we've seen a
success Mike Hopkins has had bring in
Jim Boeheim zone to the pac-12 so you
know would it shock me if a team like
Gonzaga gets knocked out no because
they've got some work ahead of them as
well and yet I think overall Gonzaga has
the most favorable bracket of the for
number one seeds speaking of the
favorable bracket I think Michigan State
could have qualified as a number one
seed not only do they not get the number
one seed beat Michigan three times they
win the Big Ten and they get stuck as
the number two seed but in the bracket
with Duke talk to us a little bit about
that positioning for that team and what
it looks like for Tom Izzo and that crew
yes ironic that probably Michigan you
know ends up as a two seed in a more
favorable region then Michigan State
does who beat them you know three
consecutive times on their home floor
and an arbor and then turned around to
close out the Big Ten championship in
East Lansing and then they get them in
the conference tournament so yesterday
I can only think if I look at that that
maybe the selection committee was
consider
all these injuries and again that's a
touch of irony there because as they
lost Morgan or Nick Ward you know even
had an injury yesterday maybe that
affected the seating and the thinking
and so sometimes that's a catch-22 you
can be winning games as Tom Izzo did but
as you have injuries the selection
clearly makes it clear they factor that
into the seating and so maybe they felt
that Michigan State of the twos was the
least likely to punch through to a final
four and then adjusted the brackets
accordingly so there's so many variables
to this but Tom Izzo and my view did the
best coaching job of anyone in the in
the high major levels you know there
look at Houston obviously with Calvin
Sampson and he could build a case for
him being a national coach of the year
as well and there are a lot of great
candidates Jay Wright maximizing his
personnel to what he lost last year four
players drafted in the top thirty three
of the NBA and he comes back wins
another Big East and then a Big East
tournament championship of the third
straight year first time in 40 years in
the Big East that that's happened so a
lot of great coaching jobs but I put Tom
Izzo's right up there and yet I probably
didn't get the most favorable seat so
Steve put your coaching hat back on here
and pretend you're Tony Bennett after
what happened a year ago again a number
one seed how are you approaching the
first round here on on I don't know if
they're gonna play Thursday or Friday
but but how are you approaching it with
your team how are you going about after
what had what transpired last year well
the number one element is those players
know and coach Bennett knows that they
lost their best player the week of the
NC double-a tournament DeAndre hunter
and so be the equivalent of Lakers
losing LeBron you know for their level
relative to college basketball or we saw
with Duke when Zion Williamson went out
the effect that has on their team and so
Virginia already played with a small
margin for error last season probably
because their style of play
the deliberate tempo
posing their preferred temple which is
deliberate kind of surgical in nature
this team is better offensively they're
shooting the ball with the best of in
the country they cover all the defensive
statistics number one and two in the
country and every important defensive
category so I think that team and coach
is aware not that there's the natural
you know anticipation that kind of
palpable
you know desire that you can feel with
the team I'm sure coach Bennett's aware
they got a punch through that first game
but I don't think they'll focus too much
on that I think the goal of the coach is
to keep your team locked in on the task
at hand and to keep the drum roll the
same there's a routine and a rhythm we
know all athletes coaches and teams have
and it's different for each team and
each coach but you want to stay with
that drum roll and that doesn't
guarantee that you're gonna have success
but you're more likely if you can
replicate duplicate and again basketball
like life a game habits right as
aristotle teaches us and so no better
team in terms of basketball fundamentals
and of strong habits than Tony Bennett
Tony Bennett's father dick Bennett grew
up in Wisconsin I used to go to Vince
Lombardi's practices and that's where he
really developed a coaching philosophy
even though it's in basketball as
opposed to football like Lombardi when
you watch their teams it's blocking and
tackling it's passing and catching its
fundamentals it's jump stops it's
footwork and pivoting it's hitting the
open man with precision right in the
shooting pocket and they're all
fundamentally sound in terms of staying
on balance not jumping in the air to
make passes but instead sitting down and
pocket passing or fan on the ball back
out in the perimeter just being solid
ball security they never turn it over
always one or two in the country and so
that family tree from Wisconsin the dick
Bennett's the Bo Ryan's the Tony
Bennett's not surprisingly great guard
at Wisconsin they all have a very
similar philosophy so I don't think
they'll be focused on the 116 but
instead the task at hand a garden people
and playing a cohesive man or a
basketball and defense creating their
offense and
and understanding and playing the game
with with an intelligence we're
listening it's a Steve Ivan from Fox
Steve Lavin from Fox Sports Steve thanks
for taking the time I can't wait for the
tournament to get kicked off here we
really appreciate you really giving us
everything we need to know about what's
to take place this weekend thanks so
much take care of my man look forward to
watch out for Wofford they shoot lights
out from distance got some senior guards
too if you're handicapped in it Racing
Form
they're dangerous that's it that's
that's inside info for former head coach
Steve lab and there's your there's your
that's your insider right there that's
the Cinderella the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience